welcome to this video the use o tomahto
from from Japan yeah Japan this isn't a
secure eous chest country it's a big
country and also with them I mean not
big in terms of length mass but they
have no hundred million people or
something and they don't have chest
really very little the chess players I
guess they mostly play shogi the
japanese version of chess if i'm not
mistaken i actually in the in the 90s i
am I played the by them number one
player of Japan he was rated about 2,300
I forgot the name to be honest it was
really funny I played I had prepared for
for him and and I was looking at the
games that i was thinking wow japan
never played someone from japan and then
i saw that he really is the number one
playoff japan okay the goon fraud let's
play d 5 I don't I don't really know it
so well here
55 yeah thank you six now black needs to
attack the center this is very likely a
known position e 6 Bishop g5 this kind
of this scan of line looks familiar ok
I'd like to I'd like to get the Queen's
of him and maybe you can play Queen a3
not exchanging Queens but it looks risky
i mean i could I can even think about h4
h4 h5 okay maybe queen a three-night a6
before this kind of idea i think i have
seen this before
maybe he's intending to play a Bishop f5
also I can take with the sea pawn it
this looks dangerous for both sides to
be honest but maybe c5 is hanging so
it's a very direct move but it's risky
it's risky no doubt if for can become
very weak but I thought I mean okay at
the moment that's Bishop c5 so you
probably cannot play why maybe you can
play yet hmm Bishop c5 rook takes e4
check okay now h5 pushing or do I need
some like a one not not not tanking a
minute IAM and then lose on time
v6 looks really slow Assad night 86 with
night before this kind of ideas but
maybe I'm wrong I mean possible he can
consider queen before here maybe trying
to exchange Queens and attacking eform
okay hmm Bishop Bishop age six very
straightforward but you can move the
bishop away of course 2 h8 but then I
have Bishop g5 this is strong actually
wait Bishop g5 rookie a group takes a
check King takes Bishop to have six
check king g8 Queen h6 look takes e4
check who should be to mis got a ton of
checks
yeah still come on isn't this should be
winning right come on oops really I can
take your first mace that team allows
that I mean Bishop before I can someone
give the check yeah and what now i can i
can give this check then he probably
needs to you need to go to e7 then I but
it's also not playable Jack Queen e5 and
Bishop b5 check yeah and this is the
wind because this candy 7 check f 627
check check black resigned yeah ed of
course cannot take 1 a 3 but I thought
it it's very critical anyway I mean
maybe I'm wrong we should beat them no
comp gives why the big etches well
Bishop f6 is the moves this is what I
was calculating and hoping that he I'm
winning Jack check and here I didn't see
a defense you can give this check check
and one one or two more checks but then
then I'm safe you know like this check
yeah even that is possible
okay so he needed to go to f6 here and
then probably a normal normal move it is
always dangerous with the open h5 but
it's it's very complicated can easily
arm can easily go astray him yeah 97
something like that maybe queen a form
they are very tense position the
computer is very confident about White's
play but I'm not so sure that I can can
easily play it over the board with a lot
of time so I'm still very tricky I don't
really know this opening but I think
right here here's the thing night a 60
should she should play alright computer
says h5 is very good okay yeah maybe
maybe if this is of course a very very
concrete position it's very hard to do
by general assessments like royal knight
a 6 this may be a more active with night
before or something if you're mated
after h5 it's not really important how
it looks okay thanks for watching